september 2003 monaco
in the monte carlo star a luxury
apartment complex a secret transaction
takes place a luxury apartment on the
fourth floor priced at four million
dollars is bought by an offshore shell
company called brockville development
limited a very unassuming name no one's
ever heard of brockville development i'm
sorry i don't know what you're talking
about but in a place like monaco the
playground for the ultra wealthy nobody
asks where the money is coming from
rockville development listed in the
british virgin islands may be the
official owner of the flat and the
company may have some people listed as
directors but until the pandora papers
were leaked no one knew who was really
behind the company or who actually owns
the flat someone has to right the owner
remained a mystery for 18 years that was
until something called the pandora
papers were leaked a review that the
purchaser had been a 28 year old russian
woman named svetlana krivanovich
svetlana nogik
svetlana came from modest means growing
up in an apartment complex where her
family shared a bathroom and kitchen
with four others in the late 90s she
worked as a cleaning lady in a store in
st petersburg but by 2003 she became the
owner of a 4 million luxury apartment in
one of the richest and most expensive
countries in the world and today her
real estate holdings are worth 14.5
million dollars she has a 3 stake in the
bank of russia is the owner of a ski
resort in sochi and as the pandora paper
is revealed she has a net worth of 100
million dollars don't you want to know
what happened between the 90s and 2003
that turned a cleaning lady into a
multi-millionaire
she got in bed with vladimir putin both
literally figuratively and for legal and
health reasons allegedly please don't
put me on a hitler spoon i'm sorry
starting in the late 90s svetlana was
the not yet president of vladimir
putin's alleged mistress by march 2003
she gave birth to a daughter
oh my god
vladimir
yelisa vietnam vladimir
her father isn't listed on the birth
certificate and poon has never admitted
to knowing anything about either woman
but the name vladimirovna is a name
derived from her father's which doesn't
look good if you're putin and right
after her birth was whence that lana
received the monaco apartment which also
explains the massive wealth that lana
has a mass since the birth of her
daughter all through this complex maze
of offshore shell companies with
nameless owners and the only reason we
know any of this is because of the
pandora papers
and we're giving away a brand new iphone
13 for free it's completely free and
ridiculously easy to enter all you have
to do is watch the end of this video to
learn how
[Music]
[Music]
sometime in 2020 nearly three terabytes
of data was leaked to the press 11.9
million records arrived from 14
different firms around the world that
provide offshore services to the rich
and powerful the biggest leak-up is kind
in history what it contains holds the
power to change elections uproot heads
of states
[Music]
and lock away some very powerful people
this leak is really part of the papers
on steroids it exposed how some of the
most famous people around the world hide
their wealth both legally and illegally
through a complex web of shell companies
trusts and foundations we're talking
presidents prime ministers the king of
jordan high-profile russian clients
close to vladimir putin the suspected
mistress of vladimir putin rockstar
celebrities and convicted criminals
we're not looking at a couple of million
dollars here we're looking at trillions
of dollars what proceeded was the
largest investigation in journalism
history dubbed the pandora papers
involving more than 600 journalists from
150 media outlets in 117 countries an
investigation that gives us a small
sliver of light into a dark shadowy
financial system that only the world's
most rich and powerful inhabit
these are the stories
traditionally getting access to the best
investments and asset managers required
you to be rich or famous like the people
we're covering in this video wall street
has always ignored everyday investors
catering only to the ultra wealthy that
divide didn't sit well for some very
smart people so they built titan a
premier investment manager for the rest
of us and today's video sponsor titan
already manages over 600 million dollars
for over 30 000 plus clients that are
just like you it's kind of like the
advent of commission free stock trading
apps but for hedge funds you get an
award-winning investment team in the
palm of your hands all you have to do is
download the app sign up deposit just a
hundred dollars and boom you get access
to award-winning investment strategies
for us-based stocks to international
stocks and even crypto assets titan's
unique time-tested strategy of
identifying a worse species of stocks
known as compounders and holding on
tights has allowed them to outperform
all the major indices and robo advisors
since their inception the firm offers
zero performance fees no lockouts a flat
rate advisory fee and record-breaking
returns it's not an etf or mutual fund
and they don't just expertly invest your
money they explain everything by giving
you course-sized seats with real-time
video updates all it takes is a hundred
dollars to get you started on your
journey towards smart investing with a
company that already manages over 600
million dollars for over 30 000 clients
get started today at time.com jake and
get your first three months of expert
investment management for zero fees
that's titan.com for three months free
the king of jordan aka you know who
[Music]
jordan is a small middle eastern country
bordered by iraq syria israel palestine
and saudi arabia because of its location
between some of the most
peaceful countries in the area jordan is
super important to the us and europe and
they all want
the same thing unlike its neighbors
jordan and his king abdullah ii are
allies that help advance the us's
military and economic interests in the
region in exchange the u.s provides aid
for millions of jordanian citizens and
refugees who live in the country mostly
in poverty jordan has very little
further land no oil of its own and is
the second most water scarce country in
the world with only a few resources and
a government where tribalism and
corruption are the norm it's not
surprising that people started getting
very angry at the system in the 2011
arab spring jordanian protesters took to
the streets asking for change they gave
king abdullah the nickname ali baba like
the character in the thousand and one
knights that stole from the treasure
cave and lived in riches his whole life
faced with massive opposition and calls
for an end to corruption the king met
some of their demands and they quieted
down then just a few years later the
protest started again and just like
every politician in the world
authorities vowed to root out corruption
again and promise to track down every
last cent of hidden money leaving the
country honesty would be the country's
new motto and the king even awarded a
prize for transparency in his own name
no one was exempt from the scrutiny in
questioning no one could hide from the
law no one except the king himself
between 2003 and 2017 an anonymous
investor referred to only as you know
who but the wealth management firms that
helped him purchase more than 100
million dollars worth of real estate in
the us and uk this included a house in
one of england's most expensive towns
luxury apartments in london and
washington dc and three beach houses in
malibu california the official owner a
company called nabisco holdings the real
owner none other than the king of jordan
himself it turns out the poster child
for anti-corruption and transparency had
been secretly smuggling his money out of
the country for years tax-free to buy
luxury real estate all over the northern
hemisphere all the while his subjects
relied on millions of dollars in foreign
aid to subsidize their fuel food and
essential needs and the united states
has been beyond the call of duty and
support to us and i just wanted to
mention
again in front of you how grateful i am
and the people of jordan for that
outstanding support in a response to the
pandora paper's release the king's
attorneys had insisted that he had done
nothing wrong and that as the king he
didn't have to pay any tax according to
the law that may be true but in a
country where most of the people rely on
1.5 billion dollars in foreign charity
mostly from the us to survive finding
out that your king has secretly bought
luxury property with money that could
have been used to uplift the people
could potentially lead that monarch to
the guillotine figuratively and
literally and that's not the only issue
the king may be facing after the release
of the pandora papers a neil chalene a
middle eastern scholar competent if the
jordanian monarch were to display his
wealth more publicly it wouldn't only
antagonize his people it would piss off
western donors who have given him money
[Music]
[Music]
the president of kenya aka client 13173
[Music]
kenya is a country with a rough pass and
an equally impoverished presence after
being ruled by colonial powers a man
named jomo kenyatta or burning spear led
a revolution against the colonial
government and became post-colonial
africa's most influential iconic leader
after liberating kenya from the
oppression of colonialism he vowed to
give freedom and prosperity to every
kenyan a noble message that was a
complete lie instead of uplifting the
people he kept a chokehold on the
country turning it into a one-party
state detaining and torturing his
opponents instead of giving back the
land the colonial powers controlled he
bought one-sixth of the land for himself
for almost nothing for most kenya's it
seemed that they just traded one devil
for another from living under the rule
of the white man to being crushed by one
of their own when jomo kenyatta
eventually died he was replaced by a guy
named daniel moy and again instead of
improving life in kenya muay made the
government even more authoritarian and
stole 2 billion over the course of his
time in office that's where our guy uhu
kenyatta comes in the son of jomo
kenyatta uhu saw how sick everyone was
with all the corruption so naturally he
ran for office under the banner of being
an anti-corruption activist he made it
clear at every rally that destroying
corruption was his only goal in life and
it worked in 2013 he became the
president of kenya he promised food
water and electricity for all he even
vowed to give a 20 of his salary as
president for the people you know he
would be the spear that destroyed
corruption stealing and lying except he
did none of that and to his panamanian
law firm alkago he became known only as
client 13173
client 13173 is the owner of various
shell companies all over the world used
to accumulate millions upon millions
upon millions of hidden wealth for
decades
what we own what we have is open to the
public today 73 of workers in kenya earn
less than 450 a month while the
president of kenya and his family are
worth more than half a billion dollars
and don't forget that we have the iphone
giveaway at the end of the video
[Music]
pakistan's prime minister
he's a pakistani cricket legend a
celebrity a national hero an
anti-corruption trailblazer and the
prime minister of pakistan imran khan
was famous long before he became prime
minister a cricketer for the national
team
he had people shouting his name for
years before he decided to run for
office like our friend in kenya khan
knew the average pakistani hated
corruption and wanted to see real change
in the government but khan quickly
realized that in order to win he would
need to start making some bold claims
and really rally the people behind him
so he turned to a classic yet another
political campaign based on a promise to
destroy corruption in all his forms his
household name mehi got all the best
sponsors and his likability meant that
everyone believed him when he vowed he
would build a new pakistan a pakistan
for the people even his party name was
the pakistan movement for justice his
campaigns did well and people seemed to
love the idea of having a celebrity as
their prime minister but something was
still missing he needed that final boost
to shift the votes in his favor and it
came in the form of the panama papers a
similar leak that happened in 2016 not
to be confused with the recent pandora
papers the panama papers revealed that
the sitting prime minister had massive
offshore accounts and that his daughter
was the secret owner of several luxury
apartments in london the public was
outraged their prime minister was just
as bad as the rest and of course khan
saw his chance he led protests all over
the country demanding the prime minister
step down he got the support of the
military and the people and it was only
a matter of time before he found himself
elected as prime minister of pakistan in
2018. everyone who supported him waited
in excitement for the overturning of the
government for the establishment of a
new pakistan but it never happened
instead most analysts came to realize
quote he doesn't have a problem with the
military ruling the country while they
pretended that he was in charge end
quote all those promises to destroy
corruption they seem to have been
forgotten khan simply maintained the
status quo while preaching every now and
then that he was busy reforming the
government and was doing what's best for
the people and in an ironic twist of
fate it was now his turn to be exposed
by a giant financial leak the pandora
papers turns out khan is surrounded by
donors ministers and officials some of
whom he appointed who all have money
hidden away from public view the
minister of water resources for example
has been accused of everything from
bribery to corruption to attempted
murder
he even tried to use asia city a secrecy
firm to invest 5.6 million dollars he
got from an alleged loan scandal in a
trust the finance minister of pakistan
owns one offshore company and his family
members own another three they were
registered in the say shells to hold
investments but of course that can mean
pretty much anything they wanted to mean
so it looks like the prime minister of
pakistan is gonna have a rough
re-election
[Music]
sri lankan blood money
it's the middle of a bloody civil war on
both sides people are being killed and
tortured your country is in chaos the
government is turning on itself your
people are being massacred but you look
on the bright side all this violence
makes for the perfect cover to funnel
your millions in corruption money out of
the country to buy luxury real estate
and art after all who's gonna notice a
few million dollars being funneled out
of the country during a war sounds
pretty brutal right but for this woman
and her husband whose names i'm not even
gonna try to pronounce a bloody civil
war in sri lanka was their perfect
opportunity to set up offshore shell
companies to hide their millions earned
from advising foreign companies on how
to do business with the sri lankan
government that means taking breaths in
exchange for granting access to the
economy by 2009 the nero palma family
already controlled up to 70 of the
national budget
and from 2010 to 2015 she served as
deputy minister of water supply and
drainage and according to the pandora
papers the money neuropalma and her
husband hit offshore came from
consulting gigs advisory services and of
course corruption they use this hidden
money to buy luxury properties in london
and sydney and to buy at least 31 pieces
of art stored at the geneva freeport to
avoid taxes we have a great video on how
to avoid taxes with fine art that you
can watch after finishing this video
even after her husband was charged with
embezzlement in 2016 asia city the
financial services company they used
still kept them on his clients managing
their assets worth at least 18 million
dollars and all this offshore luxury
real estate and art was made during one
of the most violent periods in sri
lankan history
[Music]
i am not talking about all these world
leaders to become the newest celebrity
gossip channel in fact if you have
enough money to hide from the government
legally i would recommend it i just
wanted to show you guys the power of
buying secrecy a power that is being
slowly eroded away thanks to information
technology these are just the first few
stories the icij who coordinated this
investigation is dripping out more and
more information almost every day so
subscribe if you want to learn more
[Music]
iphone 13 giveaway to enter to win an
iphone 13 should be included you can
choose whatever color you want all you
got to do is subscribe to the channel so
click that red subscribe button below
and pro tip you should probably make
sure that your subscriptions are made
public so that we can actually see that
you're subscribed to the channel and you
should also probably make sure that you
have an email listed on your account so
that if we choose your account we can
actually email you and contact you so
yeah subscribe with the red button below
and you're good if you enjoyed this
video our friends over at sly bean who
make amazing videos like how do the tax
havens that the people in this video use
how do they actually work they made a
video on it which i will link below that
you guys should check out if you want to
see more of me for some reason you can
follow me on instagram at jaketrain.io
thank you so much for being part of the
watch the end club that's going to wrap
it up stay dangerous out there and i
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you